nicht dass wir uns gefunden hat an einem
tag wo in berlin ganz schön was los ist
denn die korona pandemie hat die
wirtschaft im land ja doch ziemlich hart
getroffen viele branchen sind davon
betroffen ganz vielen branchen war
erstmal kompletter stillstand
und dann ist der staat bekommen hat ein
bisschen geholfen bei einzelnen
unternehmen die bei der lufthansa zum
beispiel ja mit ziemlich viel geld und
auch sonst wurde viel geld in die hand
genommen das ziel der schwarzen null ist
im finanzministerium war schon länger
kippt aber es gibt eine branche mit
einer million beschäftigten und nach
eigenen angaben 130 milliarden euro
umsatz die sagt wir sind hier vergessen
worden denn events konzerte messen
tagungen konzerte club besucher all das
was irgendwie draußen mit vielen
menschen zusammen stattfindet das geht
ja seit der korona pandemie nicht mehr
so wirklich
und das betrifft eine ganze menge
verschiedener berufe und deswegen auch
verschiedener menschen also
veranstaltungstechniker bühnentechniker
messebauer menschen die bereue zur
verfügung stellen natürlich auch viele
musiker und künstler und diese ganz
zusammen gesammelte
veranstaltungsbranche geht heute auch
die straße wir haben wir bilder
es gab da mehrere aktionen einmal gibt
es eine fuß demonstration und es gibt
aber auch lastwagen die quer durch die
stadt fahren
der zug ist noch unterwegs und will sich
um 15 uhr am brandenburger tor treffen
und dort wird es dann eine
abschlusskundgebung geben eine aktion
der veranstaltungsbranche war diese hier
das letzte hemd da wurde also aufgerufen
das quasi ja crewmitglieder ihr letztes
crew t shirt das sie immer bekommen bei
konzerten und tourneen spendieren und
ablegen vor dem bundestag um klar zu
machen das geht hier wirklich um unser
überleben gesehen
einer der großen lkws mit der forderung
bettet die veranstaltungswirtschaft und
das ganze zeit unterstützt von vielen
bekannten musikern künstlern und
menschen aus der branche oder lindenberg
hat sich gemeldet fettes brot ist mit
dabei und aber auch the bosshoss die
stehen gleich auf der bühne in berlin
sind jetzt aber uns zugeschaltet alec
völkel ak boss burns und sascha vollmer
horsepower schön dass ihr für uns zeit
habt ja natürlich betrifft uns ja auch
genau das würde ich mal sagen sie dabei
zu sein obwohl das kein grund kein grund
zur freude ist eigentlich aber wir
unterstützen uns natürlich sehr sehr
gerne es betrifft ja alle und es ist wie
schon angekündigt wurde gerade betrifft
über eine million menschen in dieser
branche arbeiten und das ist teilweise
echt dramatisch weil es einfach seit
monaten ein berufsverbot gibt wie ist es
denn ganz persönlich letztes konzert vor
wirklich vielen menschen wand war das ja
das ist lange her also wir wollten
eigentlich dieses jahr auf tour gehen im
juni hätte es losgehen sollen bis
einschließlich september an die 30 shows
ist ausgefallen letztes jahr haben wir
auch nicht so viel gespielt weil wir
eben dieses jahr viel spielen wollten
also uns geht es auch nicht gut ganz
klar ich meine wir sind seit 15 jahren
im business wir wollen jetzt nicht
jammern es ist sind ja auch maßnahmen zu
treffen wir haben eben diese pandemie
trotzdem haben wir ein bisschen sorge
weil es soll ja irgendwann mal wieder
losgehen und wenn wir im nächsten jahr
auf die bühne können dann wird es auch
bei uns knapp und vor allem haben wir
keine crew mehr und keine veranstalter
und keine busfahrer und keine licht
operator und so weiter und so fort
insofern ist es uns ein anliegen heute
hier dabei zu sein und dem problem ein
gesicht und eine stimme mit zu geben das
heißt tatsächlich habe ich euch richtig
verstanden denn die jetzt sagt nächstes
jahr geht es weiterhin keine konzerte
dann ist auch euer
das geld was ihr zusammen gelebt habe
zurückgelegt hat als jedoch sehr
erfolgreiche band irgendwann weg und ihr
müsst gucken dass wir was anderes macht
irgendwann geht es natürlich für uns
alle an die substanz wir können
vielleicht ein bisschen länger
durchhalten um uns geht es ja aber nicht
speziell es geht vor allem um die vielen
solo selbstständigen unsere crew besteht
aus 30 bis 40 mitarbeitern die wenn so
eine tour sommertour hein tour ist mit
dabei sind und davon leben und die leben
auch oft sehr planungs mäßig nur von
einer tour zur nächsten und die wird
wenn es so weiter geht einfach nicht
mehr geben und das betrifft uns dann
insofern dass wir keine leute haben die
kultur noch sichtbar machen das ist
schon ein kreislauf den es hier zur
zuwahl geht und was es braucht ist halt
finanzielle hilfe die wirklich bei den
einzelnen und vor allem bei dem kleinst
und solo selbstständigen ankommen bevor
wir zu den forderungen kommen dies ja
auch gibt es von dieser ganzen
veranstaltung auf der gerade heute seid
vielleicht tatsächlich mal über diese
situation die du gerade angedeutet hat
dass viele teurer mitarbeiter oder
menschen die auf tour gehen im grunde
solo selbständige sind die immer nur von
einer tour zur nächsten dem ist das
nicht schon irgendwie ein
konstruktionsfehler in der gesamten
musikbranche dass man bei gar nicht
richtig abgesichert ist na ja klar das
sind halt selbstständige solo
selbständige freelancer sozusagen es
gibt es in jeder branche und es ist
einfach üblich eine band geht
normalerweise auf tour nicht 365 tage
sondern ein paar wochen im jahr und dann
geben die crew member eben zur nächsten
band und generieren so ihr
jahreseinkommen
deswegen gibt's ja nicht so was wie eine
festanstellung bei einer band weil die
eben auf vielen hochzeiten tanzen und
tanzen müssen
und insofern klar der
veranstaltungsbranche ansicht fehlt in
die lobby das merkt man das schon aber
das ist genau der grund weil es eben so
viel kleinstunternehmen gibt und kleins
veranstaltet die konkurrenz ist sehr
groß ist es schwierig da auf einen
nenner zu kommen
aber dass man irgendwie zusammen findet
sind er heute bei dieser demo alle
sitzen im gleichen boot alle aus jedem
gewerk kommen zusammen und machen auf
sich aufmerksam insofern bleibt
vielleicht hoffnung dass sie
in der branche an sich strukturell
vielleicht noch was verbessert wir
sprechen gleich nochmal weiter wir
gucken mal nämlich jetzt erstmal darauf
was im grunde schon passiert ist das ist
schon ein bisschen was es gab einmal
geldspritzen gegen das club sterben das
heißt da gab's überbrückungshilfen für
kleine und mittelständische unternehmen
es gab soforthilfen für die solo
selbstständigen die ja gerade auch schon
angesprochen wurden es gab gutscheine
für ausgefallene konzerte also die
politik sagt da wenn man sie fragt ja
wir haben doch schon was getan aber die
branche sagt jetzt auch mit der
veranstaltung und der demonstration
heute das reicht nicht und meine
kollegin die niebergall hat mal
zusammengefasst wie die lage derzeit
aussieht
die klubs geschlossen konzerte bis auf
wenige ausnahmen abgesagt die branche
kämpft ums überleben
etwa 100 27.000 menschen arbeiten allein
in der musikbranche wie viele
studierende minijobber in clubs hinter
der theke stehen lässt sich kaum
beziffern
fest steht es gibt über 1000 clubs in
deutschland branchenverbände schätzen
deren verluste seit märz auf 206
millionen euro
konzertveranstalter rechnen sogar mit
3,7 milliarden euro verlust
mit vielen abgesagten festivals kommen
noch mal einige hundert millionen dazu
und bis man wieder so unbeschwert tanzen
kann
das wird vermutlich noch eine ganze
weile
da war
[Musik]
dagegen geht die veranstaltungsbranche
in berlin heute auf die straße bei uns
sind vor dem bundestag zugeschaltet
sascha und alec von the bosshoss
denn die politik sagt wir tun schon was
reicht euch dass das reicht auf keinen
fall natürlich wurde schon was getan
aber ich glaube das problem ist man muss
etwas genauer hinschauen und man kann
nicht einfach so mit der gießkanne sagen
hier gibt es ein paar helfen wir haben
das problem der solo selbstständigen die
bekommen zuschüsse oder haben helfen
bekommen heißt aber sie dürfen das nur
für betriebsausgaben an wenn das heißt
du wenn man genau hinguckt und das weiß
man hat ein solo selbstständiger der
tontechniker ist in der band abwürfe der
hat keine betriebsausgaben er hat kein
büro der hat keine infrastruktur für die
er zahlen muss der arbeitet tatsächlich
um zu leben und dafür gibt es leider
keine hilfe
denn es gibt ja doch versuche jetzt
konzerte zum beispiel doch wieder
möglich zu machen so was wie auto
konzerte ist das was über was ihr
nachgedacht habe was vielleicht in frage
käme naja gut ist es höchstens mal ein
signal um zu zeigen dass man noch da ist
aber es ist auf jeden fall keine
alternative autokino konzerte sind von
der kapazität so eingeschränkt dass man
das nicht vergleichen kann normalen
touren
ich sage grundsätzlich nähe das ist
quatsch ist wie gesagt es ist sinnvoll
auch eine bühne immer noch zu haben und
die fans hier und da zu beglücken
irgendwas zu streamen oder so aber im
grossen ganzen geht es um
einnahmequellen für uns für unsere crew
und für alles was dahinter steht und das
ist mit kleinen konzerten nicht gegeben
wie erklärt ihr euch das denn dass die
politik jetzt sagt man autogipfel macht
gestern im kanzleramt das sieht der
lufthansa sofort bei springen wenn die
sagt wir können nicht mehr aber dass
seine branche mit gut einer million
beschäftigten und mit einem ordentlichen
umsatz glaube ich die sechs stärksten
nach eigenen angaben wirtschaftszweig in
deutschland dass die mehr oder weniger
nichts liegen gelassen wird
ich glaube das liegt in erster linie
daran dass sie sehr kleinteilig ist sehr
verspielt hat es ist halt keine kein
industriezweig der so sichtbar ist in
gänze wie die automobilindustrie sondern
es besteht von aus kongress
hallenbetreibern veranstalter club
betreiber musiker künstler techniker
veranstaltungs verleihfirmen
busunternehmen cateringunternehmen das
ist ein sehr kleinteilig und die sind
nicht so strukturiert und organisiert
wie das ein großer verband oder ein
großer industrie zeigt ist zum einen und
ich glaube was natürlich auch so ein
bisschen vielleicht einfach nur von der
oberflächlichen stimmung mit der zum
beispiel dass man gesagt hat wir haben
jetzt in der pandemie hier geht es um
schutz vor der gesundheit und risiken
abwägen und feiern und konzerte geben
das ist halt wenn man ja eine party
feiern und es ist halt natürlich auch
was wichtig ist aber das geht hat um
mehr es geht halt wirklich um die
branche die davon lebt also für uns ist
das schön wenn wir mit den fans eine
party feiern aber wir leben davon unsere
quo im hintergrund definitiv kultur ist
letztendlich kein luxusgut das ist ganz
wichtig zu begreifen und es sehen viele
erstmal auf den ersten blick nicht wenn
man sagt okay dann gehe ich halt mal
eine weile auf keine konzerte aber das
problem ist eben dass die veranstaltern
aussterben oder die für die konzerte
arbeiten und das wird dem die stimme
wird erst laut wenn viele leute auf die
straße wirklich offensichtlich ist dass
hier große verluste eingefahren sind und
da ist uns heute mal ein anfang gemacht
ich glaube dann muss man schon den
zweiten blick und den dritten blick mal
beisteuern um das problem wirklich zu
sehen
jetzt gibt es natürlich schon die ersten
versuche wissenschaftlicher art zu
gucken wie man auch so konzerten
eigentlich miteinander musik machen kann
oder feiern kann
ich erinnere an die sache mit tim
bendzko und mein kollege ottfried
fischer hat mal zusammengefasst was ist
da gerade so an ideen gibt wie konzerte
unter corona stattfinden könnten
sommer sonne festival ausgelassene
stimmung
erinnert ihr euch noch diese bilder
stammen aus der zeit vor krone als
10.000 auf engsten raum sangen und
tanzten
jetzt herrscht vielerorts stille denn
seit märz verhindern die korona
schutzmaßnahmen große konzerte künstler
caterer techniker sie alle banken um
ihre existenzen kleinere aktionen
versprühen zwar etwas hoffnung reichen
unterm strich aber nicht die zeit drängt
vor allem jetzt wo selbst kleinere
konzerte im freien bald nicht mehr
möglich sind wie könnte es also zurück
in die hallen gehen
ein kriterium wäre dass man negative
tests verbindlich vorschreibt ein
zweites kriterium werden die
zuschauermenge deutschen pass und
auslass so gut wie möglich eben zu
trennen in den kleinen gruppen auch
verzerrten verzichten auf eine vorgruppe
zu verzichten also das gesamte event
kurz wie möglich zu gestalten
die arena leipzig hier gab es vor kurzem
wieder ein konzert ausnahmsweise für
wissenschaftliche zwecke rund 1500
probanden sind gekommen
sie alle brauchen eine maske und einen
negativen corona test zudem werden
bewegungs und kontakt profile erstellt
alles für die frage wie sehen sichere
corona konzerte aus den auftritt von tim
bendzko geht es daher gleich dreimal zu
bestaunen ohne mit etwas und mit viel
abstand in ein paar wochen soll es die
ergebnisse geben und damit auch hinweise
wie es für veranstalter künstler und
natürlich auch fans weiter geht das
dauert noch ein bisschen so jetzt ist es
gerade das bild in berlin abhanden
gekommen
eigentlich wollte ich erst mit alec und
sascha von the bosshoss weiter sprechen
da sind sie wieder auf sendung die hat
uns super
ja das wird noch ein bisschen dauern bis
die ergebnisse vorliegen haben wir
gerade ja gehört von diesem tim bendzko
versuch dann habt ihr eigene ideen
entwickelt was man machen könnte um
vielleicht auch über das nächste jahr zu
kommen
ich glaube in erster linie wäre es schön
wenn wir langsam uns aus dem bisherigen
alarmismus ein bisschen befreiend vor
der großen sorge und angst das ist immer
eine schlechte schlechter ratgeber
es gibt ja konzepte wie zum beispiel
wären letzte woche bei einem konzert in
düsseldorf dabei gewesen was marek
lieberberg initiiert hatte in einem
stadion mit sehr sehr viel abstand unter
freiem himmel mit masken mit hygiene
konzept ohne alkohol mit gesonderten ein
und auslass mit personalisierten tickets
also es gibt ja eine menge konzert und
veranstaltungskonzepte das problem im
moment ist natürlich dass auf grund der
besorgten stimmung vieles einfach auch
politisch genau aus dem bauch heraus
entschieden würden nämlich man sagt das
ist jetzt kein gutes signal das ist kein
gutes zeichen das sollte man jetzt
lieber nicht machen
das ist eine weile okay aber ich finde
wir brauchen bei einer million
beschäftigten dieser branche langsam ein
bisschen mehr sachlichkeit und eben
diese konzepte prüfen und gucken was
geht man muss ja auch was solche sachen
schlüsse ziehen können und lernen können
was vielleicht eben machbar ist ich habe
jetzt hier noch ein paar kommentare bzw
fragen auf youtube zum beispiel ich
schaue ja zum beispiel hier little bilbo
schreibt auf youtube wenn ich keine
ausgaben habe das hat er gerade
angesprochen als tontechniker hat man
das keine betriebsausgaben dann kann ich
mich auch mit hartz über wasser halten
und danach meinen alten job wieder
aufnehmen ist das eine alternative die
ihr euren crew mitgliedern empfehlen
würde wenn man wenn man findet dass wenn
jahrelang sich was aufbauen in einer
branche an beruf erlernen eine
ausbildung machen wenn es am ende das
ist dass man hartz 4 beantragen sollte
dann weiß ich nicht ob das eine richtige
lösung ist vielleicht kann man damit was
überbrücken aber wir sprach er gerade
darüber dass stirbt ja alles weg der
findet danach keinen job mehr
das ist auf jeden fall keine lösung man
hat einen begabten techniker unsere crew
members und teilweise auch musiker das
sind begabte menschen die kunst
ausführen und eben technisch hochbegabt
sind und die braucht man einfach da wo
sie am besten arbeiten können und das
ist die wollte man kann über brücken
eine zeit lang
man kann auch mal wir haben ein paar die
gehen auf dem bau im park verkaufen
möbel oder sind auf irgendwelchen in
irgendwelchen baufirmen unterwegs genau
wie ich schon gesagt aber das ist kein
dauerzustand und wir haben halt angst
dass die nicht zurück finden weil da
gehören sie hin was meint ihr wie lange
kann das noch so andauern also wann ist
quasi so einen break even punkt erreicht
wo man sagt okay jetzt jetzt ist
tatsächlich die hälfte der kulturbranche
in deutschland weg ich schon so weit
wird es ist soweit der veranstaltung hat
ja auch den beinamen fünf nach zwölf
also es ist eigentlich schon zu spät bzw
es ist kurz davor zu spät zu sein also
jetzt muss gehandelt werden
den leuten muss jetzt geholfen werden
jetzt brauchen wir jetzt die
unterstützung dass wir weiterhin in
unserer gesellschaft die kultur haben
was sind sehr sehr hoher wert ist in
einer demokratischen ja ich würde zu
weit gehen und sagen kultur ist auch
systemrelevant hier gibt's eine frage
auf youtube von charlie watts stockt er
möchte wissen also es geht jetzt nur ums
große geld und nicht nur die fans warum
denn nicht viele kleinere
veranstaltungen denn viele kleine sind
ja wie eine große veranstaltung ist das
vielleicht also ist das überhaupt
wirtschaftlich wenn man jetzt sagt man
macht nicht ein konzert mit 10.000
leuten sondern 10 mit 1000 in gefallen
für 5000 tiere müssen abstand halten
geht das überhaupt oder ist dann zu
teuer
ich glaube dass man das gar nicht
trennen kann ich habe das schon öfter
gehört dass man sagt großveranstaltung
geht es ums große geld geht es ja nicht
ums große geld verdienen da geht es ja
vor allem geht es darum die um die leute
im hintergrund ich meine auch große
windows wer große konzerthallen betreibt
musste ja auch irgendwie wirtschaftlich
betreiben dh eine miete die anfällt die
menschen die dort arbeiten die alle
hängen daran fest es geht nicht darum
dass sich irgendein veranstalter oder
eine blendende tasche vollmacht und
viele kleine konzerte kann man machen
und es ist ja das schöne der vielfalt
der kultur es gibt ja auch immer wir
haben auch ganz klein angefangen ganz
kleinen clubs gespielt von ganz wenig
leuten viele jahre so viele jahre uns
hoch gearbeitet und es gibt halt zum
glück beides oder das alles dass man
kleine clubs hat und große arenen und
das alles hatten wir recht und überall
arbeiten menschen und die brauchen allen
job jetzt geht es noch mal die nachfrage
zu den konkreten unterstützung wünschen
die ihr hättet ihr auch wieder vom titel
bilbo also es gibt auf der seite ich
kann das mal zeigen hier alarmstufe rot
punkt ort gibt es die forderung die sind
schon sehr detailliert da geht es um
überbrückungs programme für die
verschiedenen unternehmen zuschüsse zu
den fixkosten es geht und
kreditprogramme wo eine verlängerung
gefordert wird es geht um so was wie
steuerliche verluste rück traf und da
merken wir dann wird es wirklich
betriebswirtschaftlich kompliziert ist
das vielleicht auch ein grund warum das
ganze jetzt nicht so richtig in die
gänge kommt weil es wirklich wenn man
sich das im detail anguckt ihre
kompliziert ist und nicht einfach ich
sag mal in anführungszeichen eine
übernahme einer großen gesellschaft der
bund steigt einsteckt viele milliarden
rein und dann hat man das unternehmen
erstmal gesichert sondern es geht hier
wirklich hier um ganz kleine viele
verschiedene mechanismen wenn ich die
forderung richtig verstehe das mag sein
ja also es ist wahrscheinlich schon sehr
komplex ich denke mal der kleine bei
kleiner oder der kleine techniker der
jetzt nicht so versiert ist in
betriebswirtschaftlichen angelegenheiten
der zusicherung da vielleicht schwer das
alles abzuschätzen zu beantragen die
richtigen formulare einzureichen und so
weiter also ganz so einfach ist es mit
sicherheit nicht und es ist auf jeden
fall eine hürde für den ein oder anderen
da nicht den richtigen weg zu finden
wenn es ihnen gibt wie man ans ziel
kommt mit der unterstützung richtig oder
das ist auch nicht einfacher werden ganz
klar
und das ist ja auch nicht unser job
sondern dafür haben wir ja die politik
im hintergrund und die sollten langsam
nach ein paar monaten vielleicht bei
ideen haben sie das gefühl dass das
heute wahrgenommen wurde gab es aus der
politik rückmeldungen
das können wir noch nicht beurteilt also
wir sind hier mitten im geschehen
wir stehen zwar hier vor dem haus der
politik sozusagen aber wir sind jetzt
den ganzen taschen unterwegs vom roten
rathaus hierher getigert und sind
nachher noch auf der bühne am
brandenburger tor
wir haben jetzt noch keine stimmen
gehört aber ich denke mal es sind so
viele leute unterwegs
es kann man nicht übersehen und hier
liegen die shirts aus die letzten hemden
sozusagen ich denke schon dass wir heute
ein großes ziel erreicht haben gehört
und gesehen zu werden
dann wünsche ich euch auf jeden fall
viel spaß gleich beim auftritt ich hoffe
mit genügend abstand vor der bühne und
bleibt erstmal vielen dank an deck und
sascha von the bosshoss und euch vielen
dank für eure fragen und kommentare
und dann sage ich mal bis zum nächsten
live stream und tschüss